みなさんこんにちは
今日はですねえっと9日以上を作って
くださったみなさん声をかけてくれた人
それからここまで
とサポートしてくれたスタッフの女性
いろんな方に感謝の気持ちを込めて今日は
スピーチさせていただきたいと思います
改めてよろしくお願いします
発揮いたします
でもねさっそく1つ質問なんですけど
このままだったら
人類って滅亡すると思いますか
いきなり重いですね
1972年世界で初めて
国連人間環境会議っていうのが開かれて
co2削減を中心に環境問題に今まで
いろいろ取り組んできました
しかし今のまだ地球では森林火災
それから海面上昇による土地の賃アート紙
の沈没
いろんな大きな問題を抱えたまま
今もまだ
環境破壊ては続いています
実際私たちはじゃあどうすれば
いいでしょうか
原子の暮らしに
戻ればいいでしょうか
確かにこの暮らしに戻れば電気ガス水道
何にも使わずに地球環境に負担は絶えずに
地球環境は改善されていくかもしれません
しかしこの便利さ今便利になってしまった
この世の中を捨ててこの時代に戻る事って
可能でしょうか
僕はちょっと難しいような気がしています
じゃあ何ができるでしょ
皆さんこの言葉ご存知でしょうか
温故知新
古きを温ねて新しきを知ると言います
昔の人の知恵や技術
それらを今に生かして新しい物を作ったり
新しいストーリーを作っていく
そういった言葉になります
僕はこの言葉をこの淡路島に来て
学んですごく大切にするようになりました
今日は大きな問題を解決するために小さな
一歩
を踏み出す
インスピレーションになるために誰か1人
でもいいんでスター晴れでは伝わればと
思ってスピーチさせていただきます僕の
自己紹介をします
僕の名前は福山信一です
34世
5人家族です
3人の子どもと一人の大きさ
ちなみにあれば先日のハロウィン
パーティーでフレディーマーキュリーに
乾燥した僕です
えっ
がでしょ
でこの子育てをするときは
できるだけ自然の近くがいいなぁと思って
この淡路島に行ってきました
で実際昔から淡路島に暮らす人たちと
いろいろ関わりを持って実は僕あることに
気づきました
こちらです
あは島の人たちは昔ながらの文化日本に
残っている大切な文化を大事にしながら
生きていました
おすそ分け
お互い様
もったいない
をストアけっていうのは自分がたくさん
何かを得たらそのたくさん何か得たものを
独り占めするんじゃなくて誰かに分け与え
ます
具体的にはアオジしまってめちゃくちゃ
玉ねぎがたくさん撮れですね
その玉ねぎを獲れたものを隣の人や友達
親族に配ってもあります多分淡路島に住ん
でる人で玉ねぎをもらったことないよと
いう人はたぶん少ないと思うんですね
それからお互い様
困ったときはお互いさまという言葉があり
ます
自分が困ってたら誰かが助けてくれる誰か
が変わってたら自分がた隙に行くそういっ
た文化ですそれからもったいない
粟島の人は簡単にものは捨てません
できるだけ直してできるだけまだ使えない
かなって言ってものすごく大事にします
その中で僕が一番感銘を受けたものが実は
こちらです
家なんです
この家
僕が初めて見たときはびっくりしました
家っていうのは
その人の暮らし昔の環境もそのままで
細かいところまで昔の人の知恵や技術が
たくさん詰まっています
そのことは私は虜になりました
そして今では私はこういう空き家を見つけ
てはリノベーションをして誰かが進める
環境に戻していく
いわゆる空き家再生と呼ばれる事業を行っ
ています
同市か皆さんこの家
僕はこういう家を見つけたらねもうねぇ
ワクワクして仕方がないんです
多分いいですよねえっ
皆さん空き家についてどれくらいご存じか
少しだけ説明させていただきます
実際今空き家になったら人の手が入らなく
なると家ってのはどんどん口て言って周囲
の周辺環境や周りに悪影響を及ぼしたし
ます
その空き家の数それから空き家になる可能
性がある宇多津っていうのはこの20年間
で約1.9倍に上昇しましたそしてこれ
からも増え続けますん
さらに空き家住むのは嫌がらって皆さん
新築を建てます
新築を建てるとなると1件あたり木造住宅
です1件あたり3.3万キロの co2が
排出されると言われています
去年度日本では51万の真鍮が耐えられ
ましたつまり
co2が1.7万トン排出されたという
ことになります
じゃあでは皆さんここでもう一つお聞きし
たいと思います
日本のため子宮環境のため世界のため
も新築はさせないでー
空き家に住んでくださいって言われたら
いかがでしょ
住めますか
僕はちょっとで最初見たときはもう無理だ
ということですね
空き家のイメージで実はこんな感じです
ゴミだらけ
カビだらけ
草だらけ
窓は割れで着きます
いろんなところがねぇ
口で言います
実際これ本当に青い島にある空き家です
僕はこういう空き家と一つ一つ向き合って
きました
片付けもしました
ただ
この空き家に人が入っていくことによって
この空き家ての実は大きく変化していくと
の僕はマグあたりしてきました
ヤバくないすかこれ
うん
だから僕はこれをねストーリーっていうの
がすごくハマってしまって
これからも続けていきたいなってすごく
思ってるんです次のスライドお願いします
一つ
リノベーションの一つ僕は変わった井上氏
の術を一つ紹介したいと思いますこちらの
家は空き家になって数十年たった家です
チック建てられて50年経ったおうち
2階建てですもともと大家さんが住まわれ
た実家である阪神淡路大震災という大きな
自身も経験をしました
中はこんな感じです
まあもちろん
荷物が多く
カビくさくて昔を作りなんですごく使い
づらい状態でした
でも一つ
一つやへ一人ある女性が現れたことによっ
てこの家は大きな変化を遂げます
彼女は実はアーティストでした
関東からこちら引っ越してくる時にこの家
を紹介しました
すると彼女はこの絵を書いてきました
自分で diy をしたい
自分でデザインした家を自分で直したいと
言ったんです
これには驚きました
僕全くイメージ付けなかったです
でも驚いたからこの紙を持って僕は大家
さんのところへ行ってやらせてくださいと
いうふうに一緒にお願いをしました
じゃあお家さんも ok してくれて実際
彼女は diy あちらでもようにやって
いきました
なかまをよんだり友達を呼んだりイベント
を開いて地域の人を呼びなりしました
すると地域の人は僕たちに教えてくれまし
た
いやー実はこの家は昔の住んでいた人も
直したり
自分でたてなおしたりして
この家を住み着いてきたんだよって教えて
くれたんです
時を経て今まさに全く同じことが起こって
いるんだっていうものを目の当たりにして
僕は感動したのを覚えています
実際の完成しているまぁ途中なんですけど
こちらのです
彼女はいえ簿とアート作品に変えてしまい
ました
この秋やろ面白いところは
空き家になって止まってた時間っていうの
が人が入ってことによって少しずつ少し
ずつ動き出していて大きな変化を遂げて
いくことです
敵じゃないですかこれ
まさに僕が冒頭で紹介した古くて新しい
物語
この家を潰してしまって新しく建てること
によってはこのストーリーは生まれなかっ
たんです
僕はすごく感動しました
まさしく
大家さんがいてそしてそれを立てた人もい
て
で新しい女性が現れました
古いけれど新しいストーリーが始まったん
です
僕はこの物語が本当に大好きで本当に今
すごくハマっているというか感動している
んです
まさしく温故知新
そういうことなんじゃないかなって僕は
思います
もう少しだけ具体的に家の中の話をします
これは屋根を支えている9分針と呼ばれる
部分です
この針着車大きいもあるだなんですけど2
階建てだったら地上8m ぐらいこの
極まるたがあります
僕はこれ最初見たときにまったくどうやっ
て何をしたのか意味がわかりませんでした
重機もない時代
どうやってやっ
そしてこの木松の木が使われているそう
ですまずの木というのは
柔らかくてとても強い素材でできている
そうです昔の人たちはそれを知ってて
大工さんはこれを炊こうする技術を磨き針
として使いました
こういったものを取り壊してまた新しく
立てる意味ってあるんでしょうか
むしろこういったものを生かしていくべき
じゃないかなって僕は思うんです
次の世代でお願いします
じゃあ
そういったものを
生かしていくためにはどうすればいいん
だろうって考えました
そのためには
理解することがまず大事なんじゃないか
なって思ったんです
その理解をするために何が必要かと思うと
言葉と経験です
どんだけすごい経験をしても言葉で整理
できていなければ自分のことになったって
はなかなか言えないんじゃないかなと思い
ますまた逆に言葉だけを知っていて経験が
伴っていなければ頭でっかちの机上の空論
で終わってしまいます
今世の中はもう言葉だらけです情報手堅く
さぐれています
だからこそ今一番価値のあることは僕は
経験だと思うんです
全力で経験をして
自分で動いて頭と体と心で理解出来れば
冠ならず新しい世界が見えてくると僕は
思っていますですから若い人だし僕の若い
人たちにはとにかく経験をしてほしいなっ
て思うんです
最後にまとめの話をします
音口を進
古くて新しいもの
こういったものを見ぬ間にたくさんあり
ますそういったものを大事にして新しい
物語をつくっていきましょう
そしてもう一つ
タキサン経験してください
たくさん経験したらまだまだ知らない世界
景色は変わらないけどどんどん新しい世界
が見えてくるはずです
僕はこの2つが大きな問題を小さな一歩で
解決する手がかりじゃないかなって思うん
です
僕も昔の人たちからしたらまだまだ
まだまだ若造のひよっこです
でも
この大きな問題に小さな一歩を踏み出す
そういうふうに思ってこれからも全力で
活動していきたいとおもいます皆さん最後
までありがとうございました
[拍手]